dans le 20 minutes médias on parle de
l'humoriste Inès règle révélé en 2019
[Musique]
une puéricultrice de 38 ans la traque
depuis bien plus longtemps depuis ses
débuts sur scène bonsoir alors moi je me
présente je m'appelle Inès très vite la
jeune femme la couvre de cadeaux se
montre de plus en plus envahissante et
n’hésiteraient pas à se rendre au
domicile de la comédienne le harcèlement
ça nous concerne tous mais la
panoptionnelle va finir par devenir
menaçante avec des appels et des
messages malveillants tout se fait un
jour la roue tourne on verra ton vrai
visage
finira par porter plainte contre elle en
février 2020 le tribunal de Marseille
vient de la condamner à un an de prison
ferme pour harcèlement avec obligation
de se soigner et l'interdiction
d'approcher ses victimes et vous quelle
est la pire chose qui vous soit arrivée
avec un fan
et vous qu'elle soit la chose qui vous
soit arrivé avec un fan ça c'est chaud
c'est chaud
puéricultrice 38 ans elle a développé
une obsession pour l'humoriste inestreg
c'est fou voilà toi tu as tué un truc
relou comme ça jamais franchement
honnêtement moi les trucs de fan comme
ça à part les fans tu vois qui pleurent
après on essaie de les réconforter mais
des trucs bizarres comme ça je n'ai
jamais eu le temps non moi non plus
parce que j'ai pas de femme
[Applaudissements]
qui était tous les soirs dans mon hall
d'immeuble et elle voulait absolument
qu'on est une petite relation
et en fait elle est venue une fois et
puis la dernière fois elle était un peu
un peu moins vêtue
en fait elle venait à chaque fois que je
fais des missions en direct elle était
là pour mon retour et un soir je dis
tiens elle est pas dans le hall c'est
bizarre et je monte pour l'ascenseur
était devant ma porte de mon appartement
et là elle était totalement nue
et ce serait ce serait bien de ça
c'était très gentil avec eux parce que
elle est vraiment black bagarre elle
avait un vrai problème de de voilà
c'était une maladie mais tu l'as dit ça
en la raccompagnant chez elle
dans le lit comme on est un taxi je l'ai
effectivement raccompagner dans la rue
j'ai dit voilà c'est
vrai
Jean-Michel bizarre moi oui
il y a pas des mecs nus devant chez toi
à part des mecs qui veulent des
boulettes j'ai une histoire moi comme ça
avec avec
une femme qui était amoureuse de moi et
qui pendant deux ans il y a à peu près
un an et demi m'a envoyé à peu près en
deux ans plus de 2000 ml non plus de
entre 20 30 mètres par semaine vous avez
bloqué sur mon téléphone et le mail je
sais pas trop comment c'était mais j'ai
commencé à les lire j'étais assez
intéressant c'est de me raconter sa vie
mais avec un style très cru et c'est
vraiment j'ai même dit à maman je lui ai
répondu j'ai fini par le répondre
à te faire éditer parce que ce qu'elle
disait c'était vraiment c'était très
intéressant
par jour et des pas bien chaque fois tu
avais répondu à Daniel à quel moment
en faisant le Morning j'avais un jeune
homme qui était éperdu moi amoureux de
moi et qui appeler régulièrement au
standard et qui a commencé à appeler
mais c'est à dire deux fois trois fois
quatre fois dix fois et son discours a
commencé à changer en insultant le
standardiste le pauvre parce qu'il
pensait que il faisait barrage non et en
fait il était dans une forme
d'érotomanie c'est à dire qu'il pensait
que tout le monde nous empêchait d'être
amoureux et que moi et que voilà et que
moi je disais des des mots dans mes dans
mes flash info etc qui lui était adressé
un mec qui croyait que je vous jure que
c'est moi ça m'est arrivé et il y a un
gars un jour je sors comme ça c'est vrai
en plus et il dit ouais tu as parlé de
moi encore hier
tu as parlé de moi quand t'as dit ouais
à tout à l'heure tout ça là c'est
flippant
et tout je sais que tu m'as volé mes
trucs et tout parce que je vois que tu
mets tu mets mal et tout tous les soirs
et tout ouais bonsoir le public je crois
que je dis bonsoir voilà la nuit
je t'inviterai pas avec elle
non mais je vous jure et ça fait super
peur
voilà et puis ça a duré deux heures
cette histoire
des objets donc là j'ai quand même
demandé conseil auprès de de ceux qui
m'entourer à la radio et notamment qui
m'ont dit d'appeler la police et la
police m'a dit renvoyer tout
immédiatement ne lui laissait aucun
espoir renvoyer tous les les bijoux les
colliers les machins donc je renvoyais
systématiquement et quand je suis arrivé
sur TF1 il a continué cette fois-ci il
envoyait plus de bijoux parce qu'il
savait que je ne répondrai enfin que je
lui renvoyais mais en revanche ils ont
envoyé des lettres à peu près trois ou
quatre par semaine de 10 ou 15 pages
extrêmement bien écrite me disant voilà
que le monde entier était contre nous et
qu'il arriverait à ma voir alors et moi
après moi le gars moi le gars c'est
devenu un de mes meilleurs amis
[Applaudissements]